è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi e domani che
quindi stiamo sua piece ragazzi da un
secolo che non faccio sta frase la dico
ogni due episodi di è prevista da un
secolo che non faccio happy meals ma vi
giuro ci sono sempre dei problemi
domenica non so perché è quindi ragazzi
direi di finire con l'intro secolare che
mi occupano tutto il video è quindi
ragazzi se è video è piaciuto come al
solito lasciato il commento vi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate nella descrizione
sarebbero iscritti scrivete quindi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi
no dai che vi prendiamo per il culo devo
smettere comunque di fare sti intro
secolare perché veramente assurdo happy
halloween 2013 iniziamo con un livello
abbastanza in tema è di no no fermo
cazzo ti si vede il costume così ma mi
dispiace rovinargli il costume
maledizione rabeh chissenefrega
va bene dove sono quel cazzo sono caduto
non si sa c'è un vortice che bello
ragazzi sono entrati in un portale non
so buongiorno e non voglio rovinarvi la
festa
avete due bellissimi costumi cazzo siete
tutti bravissimi sono ciao york dolcetto
scherzetto brutto stronzo dove vai la
vedi questa falso e qui indovina dovete
la infilo oggetto scherzetto marraffa
cast dove siete ragazzi dove siete
voglio fare dolcetto sarkozy sono
entrato sono entrate in là nella bocca
di una zucca sono uscito a ragazzi non
sto capendo così questa è la cosa più
macabra che abbia mai visto
12 tempo scaduto maledetto dove ti
dovevi d'armi dolci mi dispiace ragazzi
ricordatevi nel caso busto alle forti
disarmi dolci perché perfetto con 100
scherzetto è perfetto ragazze anche lui
non mi aveva dato i dolci quindi è morta
se non le macchine più forti un po a del
secolo
bye bye ed è come se come fai a guidare
dal parabrezza ed che cazzo e ragga
scuola guida baietti da adesso in avanti
si guida col parabrezza ciao steve
per fare il giro zio vieni sto bravo
così ai concorsi fa a devo prenderla
rincorsa aspetta leggi di steve reggi
che che aprendomi annusare i piedi
lurido devo prende la rincorsa alla
ragazzi che se una situazione veramente
brutta ma ce la posso fare
poi così guai con madonna neanche gta
ste cose che cazzo succede
ok ok ok merda vai così edy veloce
veloce ma che quando togli di stima che
cazzo fai
già
[Musica]
ora che ho deciso che come guidavo prima
non andava bene quindi così è meglio by
step perché classi servendosi non mi
rubare il posto di guida che mi serve
non vedo dove vado
almeno io al tuo culo di indicarmi la
strada ragazzi che cazzo non vedo niente
buongiorno o continuate pure a lavorare
tranquilli perché sono un'offesa davanti
che mi sta sfondando tutto cio è più
potente della macchina cazzo vai cos'è
seguita nel modo giusto
raga ricordate di allacciare le cinture
comunque perché non si sa mai
bisogna sempre a guidare sicuri che
cazzo succede sono molab sono volato con
volata dove vai steve lee ha [ __ ] la
macchina quel bastardo che è stronzo mi
piace guidare in sicurezza o cazzo è un
jazzista macchina mio zio prega chi
cazzo sta succedendo non sto guidando
normalmente qualcosa mi dice di no
ragazzi e chiazzo di voto facendo non è
più livello con la macchina e senza vai
così mi sono morto va beh chi se ne
frega la mala paula ma prendi la ragazzi
non ce la faremo mai impossibile
io ci rinuncia che cazzo parlato sono
qui qui qui dove sono un uomo cratus ma
vecchio grevi nek e inaspettate linecker
grande klinge ragazza nuda dov'è mio dio
no cosa fai ad un cazzo fai ed è mio zio
ragazzi è di esista contorce dantista
yarra pando cosa fammi capire è che la
tac e non so cosa vuol dire noi due non
lo so ma carte latta che mi piace poi
così è fin crepa
non so perché ce l'ho con è di manica
sul culo adesso in avanti vai così vai
così distrugge tutto fa i massacri i
massacri più totali ciò perché c'è un
machete nel petto ma non importa noi
continuiamo massacro vai uk uccidi
qualcuno ragazzi ce la posso fare non so
perché
io che mi dovetti siena scorta non ti
trova più flash mob affatto la terra in
pericolo e io lo vengo a salvare ragazzi
sarà a livello fanta a perfetto la
abbiamo sbagliato personaggi per
salvarlo a terra cazzo succede mi è
caduto un bari perfetto york non
assaggiare il mio culo e tuo compito
salvare la terra
io da ragazzo inutile ma qualcosa mi
dice che va capo finito se scendi qui
sotto zitto zitto a meno con dio
grazie mille adesso vai fuori e salva al
mondo
vieni anche tu stronzo haga non ho
ancora capito qual è il mio scopo visto
livello ma ci sto giocando perché
navigate impressionante e andiamo
abbiamo abbiamo perso la terra è stata
distrutta e tutta colpa di york bene
cosi zombie fighter peso significa che
devo combattere contro gli zombie sto
stronzo seno zombie questo è il tuo post
sembra strano sede uno zombie adesso
come questo devi dovresti ucciderlo con
armi che ci sono sul tavolo perfetto mai
mai mai
ma che cazzo fuori strattonare ti
ucciderò col mio pene e nonostante
questo il braccio dello zombie tenta di
penetrarne il cap ranzi non so perché
tentativo numero 2 non so se ci riesco
ma ci avrà aspettate un attimo sempre e
se lo sto fuori stronzo ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta non sono i più come ma va bene
così proseguiamo per che cosa fanno uno
ciak sta mangiando un bambino uccidi
quello zombi ma e non l'ho saputo fare
una cosa che quanti cazzo di nomi già ci
sono
oddio spara spara ma perfetto ragazzi
l'unico uomo che fu in grado di sparare
con una bce farà con ragazzi e fantasmi
queste lo zombie più macabro che io
abbia mai visto in tutta la mia vita
weapon challenge challenge devo passarlo
con ed i ragazzi è di un professionista
non potete metterlo contro ste cose cioè
rendetevi conto
vai così ed è mai così è di solo lui
solo lui lì bellotto mio dio mio dio non
ci credo non ci credo livello nave
l'ultimo l'ultimo l'ultimo capitana come
sono morto chi cazzo fa ragazzi vi
presento sussidi che si mangia con le
bacchette giapponese pratiche uccidi
babbo natale ma no che troppo e natale
sono mi porta i regali maledizione e
allora lo uccido con ma che cazzo mi sa
che è morto gli occhi vado col film che
è meglio l'aspettate vai così l'ho quasi
preso subito ragazzi ma come cazzo ecco
babbo natale me lo spiegate voi è
impossibile
[Musica]
a regà non si può fare ci ho provato in
tutti i modi
eh no ma togliti è bravo inciampa
ragazzi non si può fare inutile e c
mista varia
[Musica]
così è successo no ragazzi costa ma
dovete spiegare perché sono caduto nelle
spade perché è morto dopo natale perché
chi mi sta usando il collo sono tutto
questo non ha senso perfetto raga dire
di fare qualche livello mio perché da
secoli che non ne faccio
saranno avrò passati un miliardo
scusatemi retour azione per fa vj ma
cos'è sta roba
ragazzi ma che presto z fa vj prova la
barra io l'ho pro ma sinceramente ciò
può
[Musica]
[Risate]
perché perché ragazzi faccio un ultimo
perché è la cosa in cui oggi livelli
vostri mi fanno veramente paura bello
bomb per fa vigeva vi so che per te sarà
cretino guarda c'è una probabilità molto
elevata ma ci provo lo stesso cos'è sta
roba
ma no fermo bergamo entrarci prima cazzo
fermo un attimo
ok non ho ben capito che razza di okc
siamo sparami piano
no ho detto piano non riesco a cadere ma
porca [ __ ] ce la posso fare
ciao ragazzi ce la devo fare impossibile
non si può accadere di qua ma come cazzo
fai marley oddio donna mi dà stupida più
il nervoso di cat mario sta roba fermi
ce la posso fare
[Musica]
sì sì cielo farmi mamme quattro ore per
farci quattro aree sono vivo per
miracolo faccia possiamo fare signora
catena per favore le regalo un casco ok
un casco che di sicuro ne molto utile ma
mi faccio a scendere in faccia scegli
gasco allora è proprio stronza papa
ragazzi direi di concludere qui
l'episodio perché sono rimasto
intruppato concludo più l'episodio
scusatemi ragazze d'ampezzo la non
faceva iapinis però non sempre una ogni
domenica ma stavolta ci siamo
giove solito raga [ __ ] sto livello
6 video è piaciuto lasciato un commento
vi piace anche la presa di facebook e
come non i video trovate la descrizione
sente l'eco rischi di iscrivetevi
riusciti vediamo il prossimo video bei
ragazzi
[Musica]